Hello everyone.
Today I'm going to talk about language
learning key number two,
number two,
which is phonology.
This could be number one,
but it just so happens that last time I
talked about a kind of a general study
habit consistency,
but as far as practical study and
practical skills of the language,
golf phonology could be number one.
I really think that learning the
phonology of the language is one of the
most important things.
It's the basis of all of your studies
and all of you are skills that are to
come.
The phonology means the system of sounds
of that language,
so that includes the pronunciation of
the consonants and the vowels,
but also the stress patterns and the
intonation patterns,
that kind of thing.
Basically pronunciation,
you could call it that same kind of
thing.
Now it's extremely important to learn
the final logical system of each
language you learned because it's really
what connects you to that language.
It's the thing that associated with that
language.
It helps you access your integrated
skills,
your are synthesized skills in that
language.
So what I mean by that is this,
if you learn a foreign language but you
use your native languages pronunciation
or you've just pronunciation that's
quite close to your native languages
pronunciation,
then you're never going to fully be able
to access that foreign language or
access your skills in that foreign
language because you'll always retreat
into your native language.
That funnel logical system is associated
with your native language,
so you want to stay away from that.
You want to stay away from the
phonological system of your own language
and as precisely as possible,
learn the phonological system of that
foreign language that you are studying.
In the past,
before I really figured this out,
I basically had a generic foreign
language accent.
I would use the same kind of phonology
for all the different languages I
learned.
It was just like I had a foreign
language accent that wasn't that
precise,
so it kind of work that.
The problem was there was some crossover
between languages.
So when I tried to speak one language,
I would sometimes get mixed up and say
words from the other language or I would
retreat into it on language that I knew
how to speak better because that
phonology is anchored to the other
language,
not only the one I'm learning right now.
So it's really important that you keep
those languages you learn as distinct as
possible in terms of phonology.
So how do you learn the phonology of a
new language that you are studying?
Well first you have to perceive the
phonology,
perceive the sounds of that language,
and then second you have to learn how to
produce the sounds through imitation.
Those are the two things.
So let's focus first on perceiving the
sounds.
You want to pay attention to the sounds
of the language and the distinctions
between all of those sounds.
So every beginner's language program out
there,
we'll have some kind of introduction to
the phonology of the language.
They usually call it the pronunciation
section and it will show you all of the
consonants,
all of the vowels in that language.
And just go through the pronunciation of
each one,
maybe just the sound and then an example
where it,
so you should of course go through that.
You should repeat after all the sounds,
repeat after those individual words that
they give as examples.
But then you don't want to just go
through the introductory pronunciations
of that language program.
That wouldn't be enough.
That's just giving you a quick idea of
what sounds exist.
But you want to actually hear them over
and over numerous times until you can
perceive them right then so you can't
hear them and know which sound is being
said.
So it's good to listen to some examples
of the language,
uh,
inaction.
So you want to hear some radio broadcast
or some TV shows or some interviews or
somebodies youtube channel with them
talking just like I'm talking right now,
but in the target language that you want
to learn.
So when you hear those sounds at a
natural speed,
then you can start to notice and
perceive those sounds that are
introduced in that language textbook or
on the language website.
That's your learning from.
If you don't take this time to listen
and become familiar with the sounds of
that language,
then what's going to happen is you're
going to start thinking of that language
visually.
You're going to start thinking of the
language only in terms of the
orthography in terms of the way it's
written,
and you're going to think of those
letters that you see the orthography in
terms of your own native languages,
phonology.
So when you imagined the letters in your
head,
you imagine the word that you are trying
to say,
you're going to save the sounds as you
would in your own native language.
If it was spelled like that.
Here in Japan,
there's a big problem with this.
Like I have students who learned
English,
but they learned it from someone who
doesn't really speak English.
They learned it from a Japanese teacher
in high school who doesn't really speak
English.
They just taught it from the textbook.
They'd teach them English in the
Japanese phonological system,
so they can't even perceive the native
English sounds often.
For example,
if they read the word,
uh,
ice hockey,
they'll read it as a sewer hook.
Gay,
or if they see the word birthday cake
written in English,
they will read it out loud as Butsu day
cake because they are processing the
language through their own phonological
system.
Even if I say it,
if I say birthday cake,
he'll look at me like,
what?
But if I say boss today,
KCI,
they'll understand because they're not
perceiving the English sounds.
They're not perceiving sounds of the
word in the English phonological system.
They're only perceiving it if I say it
in their phonological system.
So that's the problem we want to avoid.
So the first thing that you have to do
is to learn to perceive the sounds
before you produce them.
The second thing you have to do is to
learn to produce those sounds through
imitation.
So how can you do that?
Well,
the most basic thing you can do is to
get a teacher or a tutor or someone who
will work with you together closely and
monitor you and give you feedback about
your pronunciation,
to help you to make sure that you are
saying the sounds as precisely as
possible so that you are off to a good
start right from the beginning.
And then you don't ingrain any bad
habits of using your own native
languages phonology.
So having a teacher or a tutor is the
best way because they can give you that
feedback.
They can perceive distinctions in the
sounds that you can't perceive yet.
So it's good to have someone,
they're giving you feedback and helping
you along.
But some of you like to study alone.
You don't like to work with the teacher
right away if you're working alone,
if you're studying by yourself with the
textbook or with some websites,
you can do it.
I used to do that until the past couple
of years and I was always fairly good
with that because I'm quite an
independent learner.
But it means that you will have to
really monitor yourself and monitor your
own pronunciation and try to
continuously refine it.
But you can use language cds like the
CDs that come with your textbook and use
that to chorus or listen and repeat
after the CD you like.
You can play a a sentence and then pause
it and repeat after it and try to
pronounce it as closely as possible to
the CD.
You can do that with a lot of youtube
clips to like watch some,
some youtube channels or some interviews
or TV shows and play short bits and
pause and then repeat after it.
And then when you get a bit better you
can start to shadow videos or shadow
audio cds and that kind of thing.
So shadowing means that you try to
repeat after it as they're speaking in
real time,
so you kind of speak right after them
and try to follow them.
It's easy to get lost doing that,
but that's fine.
You just want to be able to shadow as
much as you can and get.
The basic point is to continuously
listen and produce the sounds.
At the same time,
but it's often the case that people will
do a kind of hybrid of listen and repeat
and shadowing.
Like they'll shadow as much as they can,
but when they get lost,
they'll pause the button then and try to
finish repeating and then they'll
unpause the button and try to continue.
So that's,
that's fine.
You just want to continuously hear
native speakers and imitate them and try
to produce the same sounds that they are
making as precisely as you can.
So you just need to monitor yourself
quite a bit if you're doing this through
self study,
but it can work.
Also,
don't forget the stress patterns and
intonation patterns because even though
those usually aren't the introductory
sounds that you are tight in your
language program,
those carry a lot of meaning and they
also can mean the difference between one
word and another word,
especially the stress patterns.
The stress panners can create
distinctions and meanings.
So don't forget about those.
Try to imitate those.
Those ones are not really conscious.
I mean the,
it's difficult to consciously refine
them,
but you just want to just pay attention
to the overall patterns of intonation.
Repeat what you hear,
and subconsciously you're going to
internalize those patterns without
really thinking about it as long as you
are intentionally imitating native
speakers or fluid near native speakers.
So that is language learning.
Key number two,
it is phonology.
Make sure you get the basics at the
phonology down quite well at the
beginning before you start getting into
learning all the grammar and um,
doing a lot of conversation.
Get the phonology down from day one.
It's very important.
It is the key to accessing that language
and not crossing wires with different
languages and not retreating into your
native language.
So learn the phonology and that will
help you a ton.
All right,
this is Paul signing off and have a good
thanks.
[inaudible].